le choeur de hong kong à nouveau plongé
dans le chaos sous les yeux des
journalistes les policiers multiplient
les tirs de gaz poivre pour disperser
des centaines de manifestants
les opposants au pouvoir perçu comme
trop pékin dénonçant projet de loi
criminalisant tout outrage à l'hymne
national chinois au délit qui serait
passible de trois ans de prison
les manifestants se disent déterminés à
faire entendre leurs revendications
les gens ont le droit de manifester et
de venir au rassemblement
donc je pense que c'est vraiment un abus
de pouvoir que de bloquer toutes les
assemblées pacifique et toutes les
demandes de rassemblements ces
manifestations surviennent alors que le
parlement local recommence aujourd'hui
l'examen de ce projet de loi
la situation est suivie attentivement
par les états unis déjà engagés dans une
guerre économique avec la chine des
sénateurs se sont déjà dits prêts à
prendre de nouvelles sanctions contre
pékin
de son côté donald trump a implicitement
menacé la chine de priver hong kong de
son statut économique spéciale c'est
quelque chose dont vous allez entendre
parler avant la fin de la semaine de
manière très intense je pense
la pression américaine ne semble pas
atténué la détermination chinoise de
mettre un terme à l'agitation qui secoue
le territoire semi autonome depuis
plusieurs années début mais pékin a
renforcé son influence au parlement hong
kong et des élus proches du gouvernement
chinois ont ainsi pris le contrôle du
comité de la chambre
une commission chargée de passer en
revue les projets de loi avant leur
examen
l'inquiétude des opposants s'est aussi
renforcé la semaine dernière à la suite
de la décision d'imposer à hong kong une
nouvelle loi sur la sécurité nationale
officiellement le texte vise à combattre
le terrorisme et les ingérences
étrangères dans le territoire semi
autonome
mais il permettra surtout à pékin
d'implanter légalement sa police secrète
à hong kong
le texte devrait être adopté ce jeudi
par l'assemblée nationale populaire
chinoise